freuen sie zu hause sie sich auch schon
so auf die europawahl die engländer
wählen jetzt auch mit war wohl nicht zu
verhindern und europas rechte vernetzten
sich immer mehr als team einer gameshow
die wirklich keiner sehen will orban
salvini frau le pen die in umfragen
aktuell vor macros parteien frankreich
liegt natürlich jörg merten für die afd
quizfrage wenn man brüssel und die eu so
sehr hasst warum warum tritt dann die
afg überhaupt zur europawahl anfragen
wir damian lohr
man muss quasi in den todesstern
vordringen um dann hat gegen den kurs
lernen der form auf vorgehen zu können
darauf möchte ich mit meister yoda
antworten die fresse halten er muss
weiter warten
deponieren
todesstern zum glück sind die rechten
europas auf dem weg zum todesstern in
vielen punkten total zerstritten sehr
erfolgreich sind sie aber müssen wir
zugeben in den sozialen medien inhalte
der afd werden im schnitt sechs mal
häufiger geteilt als die aller anderen
parteien zusammen ja oder wie angela
merkel sagen würde
das internet ist für uns alle noch
bauland ja besonders für uns ältere
semester die jungen sind da zum glück
viel weiter was ist denn die beste
informationsquelle für euch und finden
ist ja eigentlich die facebook-seite mit
jedoch würde ich jetzt behaupten so
würde ich jetzt einfach mal kotzen sohn
ja diese leute gucken erst wieder zdf
wenn bernd hocke das heute journal
moderiert zusammen
zusammen mit gundula grausig ja zu viel
panik vor den berühmten vielzitierten
filter blasen ist zwar übertrieben nur
1,9 prozent der deutschen beziehen ihre
informationen ausschließlich aus
sozialen medien aber wut und hass
verbreiten sich im netz tatsächlich
besonders schnell nach dem motto teil
hitler die rechten profitieren davon
dass facebook durch seine berühmten
algorithmen wütende teilweise auch
falsche meldungen bevorzugt weiterleitet
deswegen sollten die ihre algorithmen
endlich offenlegen diese facebooker
dachte sich auch unsere justizministerin
vor einem jahr
wir brauchen insbesondere auch
transparenz bei den algorithmen und ich
bin sehr froh dass facebook zugesagt hat
das wohlwollend zu prüfen wie matt oder
schnitt ein jahr später hat facebook da
irgendetwas schon offengelegt facebook
weigert sich diese algorithmen
offenzulegen ach so ja dann hat sich das
erledigt schade schade
heftiger wurde zuletzt nur unsere
autoindustrie angenommen
immerhin hat herr zuckerberg jetzt in
irland ein facebook lagezentrum extra
für die europawahl eingerichtet um fake
news zu bekämpfen
falschmeldungen das ganz wichtig werden
aber dort nicht gelöscht sondern nur als
falschmeldung im netz markiert wie
erkläre ich ihnen das stellen wir uns
vor auf dem bürgersteig liegt ein
hundehaufen
ein mitarbeiter der stadtreinigung
bemerkt dass und ruft der küste vor als
seine kollegen dazu ist ja notfall dann
diskutieren die in der gruppe ob das
wirklich ein wunder auf ist und wenn ja
dann lassen sie den haufen zwar davor
ist können aber einen zettel dran
auf dem steht achtung hundehaufen die
hat dann noch reinschrift selber schuld
mehr kann man nicht tun mehr kann man
nicht tun problem gelöst
tatsache ist 47 prozent der politischen
diskussion in sozialen netzwerken haben
thematisch einen afd zusammenhang
obwohl nur zehn prozent der nutzer in
deutschland die partei unterstützen
warum sind die rechten im netz so
erfolgreich wir schalten mal live auf
die heute-show facebook seite zum leiter
unserer zdf abteilung für young
communication ulrich von heesen ulrich
was ist das netz geheimnis von afg und
co tja wie erkläre ich da es einen alten
sack wie ihn ein wort wut
die afg hat kapiert wie das internet
über politik diskutiert emotional
es muss alles aus dem bauch kommen
bisher noch aus den mastdarm hier
original afd post runde verenden für
radikalen islam verstümmelt verbrannt
vergewaltigt warum vergewaltigen den
islamisten hundewelpen weil sie es
können deutsche schäferhunde gehen schon
nicht mehr alleine gast weil hinter
jedem busch ein notgeil syrer lauert
es geht nicht darum ob sachen stimmen es
geht um emotionen ja mohammed ist jetzt
der beliebteste vorname das siehst du
unterwegs scheiße berlin wird überrannt
von gewaltbereiten babys mit vollbart ja
jetzt seht ihr erhebliche aus sagt die
afg aber in einem halben jahr blockiert
er bei seiner hochzeit die autobahn 2018
wurden in berlin insgesamt 280 jungen
nach mohammed benannt das sind 1,26
prozent der neugeborenen man man welt
der duh analog otto fakten und internet
passen nicht zusammen
du musst die angst am kochen halten ohne
pause stoppt den ihren krieg gegen den
sarotti [ __ ] tierquäler schächten fünf
richtige schafe spd will dir dein haus
wegnehmen
so geht es rund um die uhr ist ich
möchte mein haus und sage mir wie
schlagen sich die anderen parteien so im
netz
ja ja ja die können können sie ja nicht
auf dem niveau begeben und auch lügen
und rassismus verbreiten
aber sie könnten sturm mehr machen also
mehr als das hier
ich habe angekündigt dass ich nach der
parlamentarischen sommerpause mit den
gewittern beginnen und das blatt
das findet statt
gehen sie war auf seine twitter seite
post hat seitdem wenn ich wirklich alles
zusammenzähle genau zwei tweets
abgesetzt
einen am 17 dezember und einem am 19
januar und ich sage wenn er in dem tempo
weiter
dann bringen sie im wald mit burnout ins
heim
das wäre schön für weitere videos klickt
unten und abonniert auch unseren channel
alles im kasten
ok wo geht's hier raus
scheiße